dominic rob thanks for joining us 41 of
conservative mps voted against boris
johnson and that's just 906 days
according to our stats people after he
secured the biggest majority in a
generation why did they vote that way do
you think
well look there's uh we had the vote
yesterday it's not something the
government wanted but it's something
that those who were expressing those
dissenting opinions felt was necessary
as you say the prime minister won it
with 59 that's actually more than he got
in terms of support when he was elected
leader of the conservative party um but
we've had that vote now i think it's you
know it was the prerogative of those
calling for it to have it the prime
minister won it clearly um he won it by
63 votes as i said 59
and now the most important thing i think
is to respect that result uh and to move
forward and we last night we had the
national security bill have its second
reading that's enormously important
right now with the threats from hostile
states including russia i think we
should be focused on that we've got the
leveling up and regeneration bill coming
for second reading in the house of
commons great opportunity to empower
those local leaders to drive up growth
and development in all of the uh the
so-called left behind parts of the
country we've got a national insurance
tax cut coming in july the cash grant of
400 pounds energy
rebate coming in october i've got the
the bill of rights we're finalizing the
text on there is a huge agenda and i
think it's important that we come
together and focus on the people's
priorities and get away from frankly the
westminster inside internal conversation
that has dominated okay if 32 uh
conservative uh politicians had voted
the other way
it he would no longer be in office today
how much worse was the result than you
thought it would be but they didn't and
i you know i i come on to show i always
want to k you ask very fair questions
and i always want to answer them as best
as i can but to be honest with you the
whole point is uh my whole point would
be
all of that speculation all of that
hypothetical uh debate that's over now
we had that vote the prime minister won
with 59
and we move forward um i don't think the
precedents apply because we've got a far
bigger majority we don't have the hung
parliament that people talk about in the
context of uh the the contest and the
the issues in 2018
uh with theresa may um and we've got uh
75 working majority i think that the
number still is and we've got this
packed agenda and of course for the glue
and the conservative party i think as
well as the public interest the interest
of the country is move forward uh
deliver on the agenda from national
security through to leveling up to
deliver on that relief for the cost of
living we've got a bill of rights i'm
looking forward to bringing forward a
victims bill parole reform uh all of
that important work that brings people
together but above all focuses on what
our constituents and the public expect
and that's where our energy should lie
now
why then take time out of your busy day
to appear on tv twice in 24 hours and
write an opinion piece in the sun
newspaper if he's as safe as houses to
make the case i always accept the
invitation to come and speak to uk wild
horses wouldn't keep me from doing the
early morning round uh as you well know
but look but we do need to make the case
we've got two years to deliver and
demonstrate we're delivering and i think
we're the ones with the plan i think
this prime minister
is full of vision determination and if
anything renewed energy to get off the
westminster insider track onto the
outward facing
agenda of delivering for the people
and i believe that we've got the plan
the energy and the team uh which labour
can't match they can't rival i don't
think they're doing anything other than
carping from the sidelines and that is
where all the energies of all our mps
and the whole government should be
but if you if you can't convince or he
can't convince three out of four of your
back benches what hope have you got of
convincing the country
well the conservative party has always
been a broad church there's always
dissenting voices i've ever since i've
been here as i always say mr rob people
died in broad church
well
that may be true but actually one of the
the gifts of the conservative party um
is that it does uh house
if you like a broad tent a diverse
opinion but that must come with the
galvanizing force and energy of coming
together uh to deliver for the people
and not make the life easy not give a
gift to the labour party when we do that
we're at our best and i think uh you
know it was only a year ago we won
hartley paul which uh we hadn't won
is it for 60 years um as you said
politics changes very quickly but we
need to be on the front foot delivering
for the people and i think that's the
best galvanizing force for the country
but also for my colleagues
yeah this is what one of your elder
statesmen said former conservative
leader lord hague
while johnson has survived the night the
damage done to his premiership is severe
in his words and he should know
votes have been cast that show a greater
level of rejection than any tory leader
has ever endured and survived
the writings on the wall
i look william is free to he's been a
leader of the conservative party he's a
commentator now he's free to commentate
i'm frankly focused on action and what
we do next and what we do is we press
through the national security bill as i
said critical for dealing with those
hostile states in particular think about
russia the leveling up and regeneration
bill i think critically important again
shows that detailed work on the plan
that only we the conservatives have got
to lift uh the life prospects right
around the country i'm looking forward
to debating the bill of rights and
passing that unprecedented piece of
legislation through parliament i'm
looking forward to working with pretty
patel the attorney general suella
fernandez as well on the um whole law
enforcement agenda we're gonna be
talking more about that in particular
putting victims at the center reforming
parole so we can galvanize around those
things or we can continue to uh
commentate and debate with um with the
commentators i think that the former is
by far uh the right thing to do for the
country and the recipe for success for
the conservatives but how are you going
to stop any civil unrest within the
party blue on blue as it's called even
at the top echelons i mean the culture
secretary nadine doris yesterday uh
talking about the former health
secretary jeremy hunt who she used to
work under she actually tweeted
your pandemic preparation during six
years as health secretary was found
wanting and inadequate your duplicity
right now is destabilizing the party and
country to serve your own personal
ambition more so
i mean
how are you going to stop stuff like
this happening if you're trying to be a
part of united i think you make a good
point look what i'd say is the more we
talk about the westminster process or
the internal process the conservative
party the more of that there will be i
like and respect both nadine and um and
jeremy hunt he's one of my sorry
neighbours and we will need all of the
energies of all of our mps
if we're going to deliver for the people
on the priorities that i've described
and frankly if we were going to take the
game to labor which uh is in a total
mess and we're letting off the hook if
we're talking to each other um so i
think it's time to come together and i
think you make the point very well
well the door is certainly open for
months of infighting perhaps made even
worse if you lose the two by-elections
which are coming up in just a couple of
weeks time you'll say in response to
that because i've spoken to you a lot
let's wait in the sea looking at the
polls
it's disastrous for you especially in
wakefield
well actually i was noticed one of the
polls that came out over the last 24
hours had uh national polls rather than
by election polls had uh us closing the
gap with labour so what i would say is
if we want to continue to do that in
relation to by-elections uh but also uh
what will matter ultimately is the
general election get on the front foot
focus on the people's priorities come
together and deliver delivered deliver
on our agenda from the economy and the
cost of living to the the crime fighting
agenda to the leveling up agenda and
that's the it's very simple and
straightforward that is the recipe for
success i believe it's a positive agenda
that brings the country together but
also my colleagues in the conservative
party together and we should be
relentlessly focused on that
that was a body swerve worthy of the
wigan rugby league front row let me tell
you what about these by-elections
look my elections are always challenging
but look we we as i said politics moves
very quickly um uh i think we've got
great candidates uh in both tiverton uh
uh
and um uh wakefield uh we uh we won
hartley pool
a little more than a year ago but
by-elections aren't the acid test the
acid test is the general election we've
got probably two years and our focus
should be relentlessly on delivering
sustainably long-term because that's the
stuff people remember people don't
remember if we're honest and i think a
lot of the pollsters would say is they
don't remember by-elections uh come the
general election it's an opportunity to
express different views about different
things it's not the opportunity to
change the government and when you have
the opportunity to change the government
of the general election people will care
about the bread and butter issues which
is why we need to be focused all our
energies all of our the talent we've got
right across the piece in the
conservative party in government on
delivering for for the people of this
country that's what matters there's
nothing else really that matters
everything else is a distraction from
that laser-like focus
okay it's a litmus test on the
popularity of the prime minister is
exactly what it is are you saying even
if
are you saying that even if you lose
these two by-elections the prime
minister is still solid as a rock in the
building behind me look i will be
fighting tenaciously to win uh both of
those we've got great candidates i've
been down
to tivoton i will go up to waitfield i
think they're both important but but
they aren't acid tests by-elections
never are we often win back at general
elections
seats that go uh one or other way in a
by-election and that's true of all
governments and what matters now
is not the the froth of uh westminster
or indeed uh by-elections what matters
now is are we on the front that
delivering for the people of this
country and as i said i think we should
all be focused on that national
insurance tax cut in july the energy
rebate of fort with cash ground to 400
pounds in july uh in sorry in october
forgive me the national security bill
the regeneration leveling up bill the
bill of rights the crime fighting agenda
that's the forward momentum that we need
and i think uh bluntly it's the right
thing for the country it's the right
thing for conservative mps to rally
behind yeah you've also got to look
forward to the covet inquiry and the
privileges committee inquiry into what
happened in the building behind me
look
these are all
challenging times we've been through
brexit uh the pandemic as you rightly
say the likes of which we've never seen
before uh we've got a war in europe but
i believe in all of these areas the
prime minister and the government got
the big calls right and ultimately
that's the question and the judgment
that's the that's the question well can
you say that in a withering tone prime
minister deputy prime minister look at
what happened with the care homes
literally elderly people were being sent
out of hospital without being
covertested to go into care homes then
we had the parties here then we had 12
billion pounds for our test and trace
where on earth did all of that money go
then we had four billion pounds being
written off for fraud as far as the
furlough was concerned then we had the
national insurance increase and then
we've had the highest taxes in 70 years
so okay let me retort allow me to list
the positives and miss the challenges
the fastest vaccine rollout and booster
campaign in europe as a result all of
which the pm uh stewarded through from
the r d trials to production uh as a
result of which we got the economy
opened up quicker uh with the fastest
growing economy in the g7 last year
second fastest predicted this year we're
the ones with the plan on the cost of
living and the prime minister uh uh
has shown the kind of leadership in
ukraine that meant when he addressed the
ukrainian parliament you had union jacks
flying we've had people singing god save
the queen across towns and cities uh all
over ukraine i believe that is the the
strong leadership but i don't doubt
these have been challenging times kay
but the big calls this prime minister
got right
okay we're out of time but one doesn't
cancel out the other does it
no no you're quite right and that is why
in two years time the public will assess
uh this government on the big issues of
the day and i think we've got the
answers and labor doesn't